NVIDIA called and said, "We'd like you to come here
and start looking at how we can apply this in a more product-orientated sense."
Yeah, NVIDIA was a great partner in the research.
They were giving us access to the hardware and some of the early specs
so we could think about where they were going and how it influenced our research.
When we were all said and done, I got the opportunity to come to NVIDIA and do it for real.
I started the CUDA group with one other guy.--it was just the two of us--
and we hired in a compiler and library and QA guys, and we slowly built our way up,
this time really taking the learnings from Brook and starting over a little bit,
also influencing some of the hardware design, the hardware architecture.
What could we do the generalize the architecture just a little bit to make it a little easier,
to eliminate those roadblocks that we discovered with Brook,
and then eventually come up with our sort of CUDA 1.0?
So how long did you take from the day you got there and you started on this project
to the time it launched?
It was probably a good 2 years of development work that we were pushing to do this work.
A lot of it was spec writing, kind of coming up with paper specs, writing some sample code examples,
seeing if it was usable, easy to use,
picking between a variety of different approaches for how to express the parallelism.
Eventually we latched on to a very basic idea of threading
because we knew that most C and C++ programmers understood the concept of a thread,
at least at the simplest level, and if we could latch on to that
we could actually present a program model that was familiar.
Very early on in the CUDA project we did a road show.
We went out and we talked to every customer who was willing to talk to us, saying,
"Tell us your problems around computing. How can we help you?"
And one of the big sentiments was they didn't want to learn a new language.
And while it was tempting as a researcher to come up with the new parallel programming language
of the world, they just wanted an easy way to get access to the performance,
and they had a bunch of C or C++ or Fortran programmers.
So when we set out to start CUDA, we made sure it's not a new language.
It's just a couple of simple extensions to C and C++
so that anyone who knows those languages plus has a basic understanding of threading
could get access to the GPU's performance.